and thousands of NHS workers which
includes nurses from the Royal College
of Nursing will now strike this Thursday
the 15th of December and again on the
20th in England Wales and Northern
Ireland
ambulance workers including paramedics
Emergency Care assistants and call
handlers will take industrial action on
the 21st of December and the 28th
postal workers Were Striking yesterday
and are expected to continue on a number
of days this month rail strikes will
take place over four days this week and
from Christmas Eve until early on the
27th of December more are also planned
in January
and Border force staff driving test
examiners security staff on Eurostar and
some civil servants are also walking out
this month with the latest here's our
political correspondent Rob Powell
health workers on strike in Northern
Ireland at the beginning of a week of
disruption across the UK that will
impact almost everyone in some way we
work long hours we're undrepared we're
understaffed we can't deliver the
service that we should be delivering
we're not just out here for more money
we're out here for safe staff and levels
of course it's difficult but we're
forced into this time after time now it
seems to be a regular thing and it's
always coming down to the Tories
tonight in Westminster hastily arranged
talks ahead of a nurse's strike on
Thursday ended in bitterness with the
health secretary telling unions higher
pay Rises would mean less money for
Frontline services
union leaders accused the government of
belligerence and having too little to
say there is no other point in us having
conversations about other things of
course we're willing to do that in
addition to talking about pay but they
can't be completely instead of talking
about pay
up the road ministers attend a cobra
emergency committee are you doing enough
to avert strikes on the agenda deploying
troops to drive ambulances and check
passports hello Minister are you
comfortable with troops standing in for
striking workers
but the man coordinating the government
response is clear there will still be
disruption at a time when people are
struggling both with the consequence of
the situation in Russia Ukraine as we
emerge from covert and indeed this
winter weather I don't think most people
think it's fair and reasonable to
undertake these strikes so my message to
them would be even now please call them
off
so with both sides seemingly dug in the
outline of a deal is hard to make out
ministers appear to be shifting their
focus from averting this month's strikes
to tackling their impact the big risk
for Rishi sunak though is that with more
unions balloting for Action the public
may decide the country simply isn't
functioning and blame the government for
not dealing with it
for labor a carefully calibrated
position no commitment to pay Rises and
no vocal support for the strikes just
criticism of the government's approach
the health secretary's reaction to the
strikes has been a complete joke to say
that he's willing to talk to the RCN
about everything other than the issue
they want to talk about that's not
serious
and it's not the only dispute rail
workers today rejected a deal that could
have averted some Christmas strikes
so there'll be more of this in the
months ahead
the prospect of a smooth running
Christmas slipping away Rob house Sky
News in Westminster